>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HAPPY TUESDAY.
THERE IS PROBABLY NO INSTITUTION
IN AMERICAN LIFE THAT HAS MORE
EFFECT ON HOW YOU LIVE BUT THAT
WE TALK ABOUT LESS THAN THE
FEDERAL RESERVE.
PEOPLE DON'T CARE TO TALK ABOUT
THE FEDERAL RESERVE BECAUSE IT
SEEMS VERY COMPLEX AND A LOT OF
WHAT IT DOES IS IN FACT COMPLEX
UNLESS YOU HAVE A GROUNDING IN
MONETARY POLICY, IT IS HARD TO
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING ON.
BUT THE BASICS ARE NOT THAT
COMPLICATED, ACTUALLY COME IN
HERE ARE A FEW.
THE FEDERAL RESERVE WAS CREATED
WAY BACK IN 1913 BY AN ACT OF
CONGRESS AND HAD TWO MAIN.
MAXIMIZE EMPLOYMENT AND KEEP
PRICES STABLE, KEEP INFLATION
UNDER CONTROL.
THOSE ARE VIRTUOUS GOALS.
BUT IT MAY BE A MEASURE OF THE
WAY BUREAUCRACIES WORK THAT OVER
TIME, THE FEDERAL RESERVE HAS
ACTIVELY UNDERMINED BOTH OF
THOSE OBJECTIVES.
IT IS THE CLASSIC STORY OF THE
FIREMEN TURNED ARSONIST OR FOR
THAT MATTER, THE COVID CZAR WHO
HELPED CREATE COVID, IRONY OF
IRONIES, SEEMS LIKE WE HAVE A
LOT OF THOSE, LATELY.
IN THE CASE OF FEDERAL RESERVE,
QUANTITATIVE EASING, THE MAIN
THING IT HAS BEEN DOING SINCE
THE FINANCIAL CRISIS OF 2008.
EVERY MONTH, FEDERAL RESERVE
OFFICIALS PRINT MORE THAN
$100 BILLION NEW, IN AMERICAN
CURRENCY, AND THEY INJECT THOSE
DOLLARS INTO OUR SYSTEM VIA
BUYING ASSETS LIKE BONDS AND
SECURITY.
THIS IS NOT A NORMAL THING TO
DO, IT IS A RADICAL THING TO DO,
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE TEMPORARY,
IN RESPONSE TO A CRISIS.
IN MEDICAL TERMS, QUANTITATIVE
EASING IS LIKE CHEMOTHERAPY.
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN IT CAN SAVE
YOUR LIFE, BUT FUNDAMENTALLY, IT
IS POISON IF YOU KEEP SAYING IT,
IT WILL TELL YOU, PRETTY MUCH EE
AGREES ON THAT.
AND PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THAT ULTIMATELY,
QUANTITATIVE EASING CAUSES --
YOU DON'T NEED TO BE AN EXPERT.
THE MORE MONEY YOU PRINT, THE
LESS THAT MONEY IS WORTH.
IT IS SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
YOU BUY DIAMONDS BY THE CARROT,
BUT DIRT BY THE YARD, OVER
ABUNDANCE DECREASES VALUE.
SO EVERY NEW DOLLAR YOU PRINT
BUYS LESS.
IF YOU KEEP PRINTING THEM YOU
WIND UP DEVALUING YOUR OWN
CURRENCY.
THAT IS ONE THING A RESPONSIBLE
GOVERNMENT SHOULD NEVER DO.
THEY MAY ENRICH BANKS AND MAKE A
TINY NUMBER OF BIG INVESTORS WHO
GIVE TO THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
BUT DEVALUING YOUR CURRENCY
SCREWS EVERYONE WHO WORKS, AND
THAT IS IMMORAL.
THOSE ARE EXACTLY THE PEOPLE
THAT A LEGITIMATE GOVERNMENT
OUGHT TO BE TRYING TO HELP.
AS ITS CORE MISSION.
AND YET, THEY ARE NOT.
ALL THESE YEARS LATER,
QUANTITATIVE EASING CONTINUES.
THEY ARE STILL DOING IT.
ON WALL STREET, THEY JOKE ABOUT
HOW IT IS GOING TO GO ON
FOREVER.
THEY CALL IT QE INFINITY, IT'S
AN INCREDIBLY RECKLESS POLICY
AND EVERYONE KNOWS IT.
VERY MUCH VERY MUCH PUTS PEOPLE
GETTING RICH FROM IT.
FOR THE BETTER PART OF A YEAR,
FED OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN
PROMISING ARE GOING TO STOP
DOING THIS.
THEY HAVE SWORN THEY WILL GET
SOBER.
THEY HAVE VOWED TO BEGIN A
PROCESS CALLED TAPERING.
THAT MEANS THEY WILL START TO
GRADUALLY SLOW THE MONEY THEY
PRINT.
AT A FED MEETING IN APRIL,
OFFICIALS SAID THEY WOULD START
TO DO IS VERY SOON, THEY WOULD
TAPER, BUT THEY NEVER DID.
THEY MADE THE SAME PROMISE
THROUGHOUT THE SUMMER, BUT
AGAIN, THEY DIDN'T.
THE BINGE CONTINUED.
THIS MORNING, THE VICE CHAIRMAN
OF THE FED ONCE AGAIN INSISTED
TAPERING IS ALMOST HERE, WE ARE
ABOUT TO DO IT.
THE CONDITIONS TO BEGIN DETOX HE
SAID HAVE ALL BUT BEEN MET.
AND YET, AS OF TONIGHT, THE FED
IS STILL PARTYING WITH YOUR
CURRENCY LIKE THIS IS THE
RICHEST COUNTRY IN THE WORLD AND
ALWAYS WILL BE.
SO WHAT ARE THE EFFECTS ON OUR
COUNTRY?
IN THE SHORT TERM, AS WITH
VODKA, IT MAKES EVERYBODY FEEL
PRETTY GOOD.
NICE TO BE A I'M COMING YOUR
LIPS ARE NUMB, AND YOU CAN
BARELY SEE, AND YET SOMEHOW,
THE BREAKFAST MEETING OF
DOWNTOWN IN FIVE HOURS WHERE YOU
HAVE TO GIVE A DETAILED
PRESENTATION TO YOUR POSSIBLE BE
NO PROBLEM AT ALL, YOU GOT THIS.
EXCEPT YOU DO NOT HAVE IT AT
ALL, MORNING ALWAYS COMES AND IT
IS ALWAYS WORSE THAN YOU THINK.
AMERICA'S QUANTITATIVE EASING
HANGOVER IS GOING TO BE UGLY.
BENEATH THE MANUFACTURED
EUPHORIA OF OUR TOPLINE ECONOMIC
NUMBERS, GOOGLE IS KILLING IT,
RECORDS FOR AMAZON, SAYS CNBC.
BENEATH ALL THAT GARBAGE, THE
ACTUAL AMERICAN ECONOMY IS IN
TROUBLE, AND THERE ARE MANY
SIGNS OF IT.
LABOR MARKETS ARE TIGHT RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE A LOT OF AMERICANS
ARE SIMPLY DROPPED OUT OF THE
LABOR FORCE.
4.3 MILLION PEOPLE WALKED OFF
THE JOB LAST MONTH, SOME WERE
FORCED OUT BY JOE BIDEN'S
VACCINE MANDATES.
PROJECTIONS FOR GDP GROWTH JUST
DROPPED FROM 6% TO 1.5%.
SMALL BUSINESSES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE DYING.
AND MAYBE MOST OMINOUS OF ALL,
INFLATION IS HERE.
IT IS NOT JUST A TEMPORARY
PROBLEM CAUSED BY
COVID-DISRUPTED SUPPLY CHAINS,
IT IS ABSOLUTELY REAL.
>> THE AMERICAN ECONOMY STARTING
TO SIZZLE ONCE AGAIN AS IT
EMERGES FROM THE PANDEMIC, AND
WORKERS PAYCHECKS ARE, TOO, WITH
BUSINESSES PRACTICALLY BEGGING
FOR HELP.
BUT THERE IS A FLIP SIDE TO ALL
THE RAISES, AND THAT IS
INFLATION.
PRICES RISING AT THE FASTEST
RATE SINCE 2008.
EVERYTHING FROM WASHING
MACHINES, UP ALMOST 30%, TO
FURNITURE, UP 11%, AND
TELEVISION SETS, UP 8%.
>> Tucker: SO, IT IS HAPPENING
THROUGHOUT THE ECONOMY, NOT JUST
WASHING MACHINES AND
TELEVISIONS, CONSUMER
ELECTRONICS, IT IS EVERYTHING
INCLUDING THE BIG THINGS.
TRY TO BUY A HOUSE.
IT IS NOW MORE EXPENSIVE TO BUY
A HOME THAN IT HAS EVER BEEN AT
ANY TIME IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
THE MEDIAN EXISTING HOME PRICE
LAST YEAR WAS $310,000.
IT IS NOW OVER $356,000, AND A
LOT MORE IN THE ZIP CODES YOU
MIGHT WANT TO LIVE IN.
PART OF THE REASON IS THE COST
OF BUILDING MATERIALS.
THEY ARE CLEARLY OUT OF CONTROL.
LAST OCTOBER, LOEBER WENT FOR
ABOUT $580 PER 1,000 BOARD
FEET.
AS OF LAST WEEK, IT WAS 712.
LAST AUGUST, USED CARS, WHICH
YOU MIGHT NEED, WERE SELLING FOR
AN AVERAGE PRICE OF $21,000.
THIS AUGUST FROM A YEAR LATER,
THEY WERE ALMOST $28,000.
SAME CAR, $7,000 MORE.
OVER THE SAME.
MAX, BY THE WAY, AS YOU WELL
KNOW, THE PRICE OF GAS JUMPED A
FULL DOLLAR A GALLON AND A LOT
MORE THAN THAT
IN SOME PLACES.
FED TO THE GROCERY LATELY?
THE COST OF A STAKE IS UP BY $2.
A POUND OF BACON COSTS OVER $7
RIGHT NOW.
SUDDENLY EVERYTHING COST MORE,
EGG, MILK, COFFEE, MUSTARD,
ET CETERA, ET CETERA, THESE
ARE NOT LUXURY ITEMS OR A TRIP
TO SAINT BARTH'S, THESE ARE
THINGS YOU BUY EVERY WEEKEND YOU
HAVE TO BUY.
THE QUESTION IS, ARE YOUR WAGES
RISING AS FAST AS YOUR COSTS?
WELL, LET'S SEE.
VEGETABLE OIL IS UP 60%.
SO PROBABLY NOT.
AND THAT MEANS YOU ARE GETTING
POORER, WHETHER YOU REALIZE IT
OR NOT.
BUT THAT IS WHAT INFLATION DOES.
IT CAUSES POVERTY.
SO, BECAUSE WE CAN PROVE THAT
THE POPULATION OF THE
UNITED STATES IS GETTING POORER
BY THE DAY, YOU'D THINK THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WOULD BE
ACTIVELY CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
AND WORKING TO MAKE IT BETTER
BUT THEY ARE DOING THE OPPOSITE,
THEY ARE ACTIVELY MAKING IT MUCH
WORSE.
AND HERE'S HOW THEY ARE DOING
IT, BY SPENDING.
NO GOVERNMENT IN THE HISTORY OF
THE WORLD HAS EVER SPENT MORE
MONEY THAN JOE BIDEN'S SPENDING
RIGHT NOW.
THAT IS A FACT.
IN FISCAL YEAR 2019, JUST THE
OTHER DAY, THE ENTIRE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SPENT $6.6 TRILLION,
THEN COVID HAD THE FOLLOWING
YEAR AND THE NUMBERS WENT UP BY
40%.
FEDERAL SPENDING IN 2020 JUMPED
TO $9.1 TRILLION.
WAS THAT TOO MUCH?
OF COURSE IT WAS.
WHAT DID WE GET FOR IT?
NOT ENOUGH.
HERE IS THE SHOCKING THING.
UNDER JOE BIDEN, AS COVID
RECEDES, IT IS GOING UP EVEN
HIGHER BECAUSE THEY ARE NO
LONGER USING COVID AS A PRETEXT.
THROUGH THE END OF THIS AUGUST,
WHICH IS JUST A MONTH AND A HALF
AGO, THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ALREADY SPENT MORE IN 2021 THEN
IT DID OVER THE ENTIRE CALENDAR
YEARS OF 2019 AND 2018.
SO, ALL OF THIS DRIVES INFLATION
TO SCARY LEVELS.
BUT THEY ARE NOT SCARY TO
EVERYONE.
IF YOU ARE A MASSIVELY LEVERAGED
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION THAT WAS A
LOT OF MONEY TO A LOT OF PEOPLE
AND THAT IS HOW YOU'RE MAKING
YOUR MONEY, THIS IS NOT
NECESSARILY BAD NEWS.
IF MONEY IS WORTH LESS, THAT
MEANS YOUR DEBT SERVICE COSTS
LAST.
YOU DON'T FEAR INFLATION,
INFLATION HELPS YOU.
THE PROBLEM IS IT CRUSHES THE
AMERICAN MIDDLE CLASS.
NOW, IN A NORMAL COUNTRY, THIS
WOULD BE A HUGE CONCERN, BUT
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE OUR
POLICIES DON'T CARE ABOUT THE
MIDDLE CLASS, THIS IS A BARGAIN
WELL WORTH MAKING.
"BLOOMBERG NEWS" JUST PUBLISHED
A PIECE WITH HIS HEADLINE WHICH
WE ARE NOT MAKING UP, THEY ARE
STILL WRITING DISASTER, "AMERICA
NEEDS HIGHER, LONGER LASTING
INFLATION."
IF YOU CAN EVEN IMAGINE IT --
DOES AMERICA NEED MORE
EMPHYSEMA, TOO?
IT IS GROTESQUE.
NORMAL PEOPLE DO NOT READ
"BLOOMBERG NEWS" AND MAY BE
UNAWARE OF THESE ATTITUDES EXIST
IN WHAT THEY ASSUMED WAS OUR
COUNTRY, AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WOULD LIKE TO
KEEP IT THAT WE HAD TO KEEP THE
POPULATION FROM FINDING OUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING.
SO HERE'S TREASURY SECRETARY
JANET YELLEN, WHO ONCE RAN THE
FEDERAL RESERVE, MORE
RESPONSIBLE THAN EVERY SINGLE
LIVING PERSON FOR YOUR GROWING
POVERTY.
HERE SHE IS ASSURING YOU THAT $7
BACON IS NOT ACTUALLY A PROBLEM,
THAT IS NOT REALLY INFLATION, IT
IS SOMETHING CALLED TRANSITORY
INFLATION.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
AT RISK OF HYPERINFLATION.
WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL MONTHS OF
HIGH INFLATION THAT MOST
ECONOMISTS, INCLUDING ME,
BELIEVE WILL BE TRANSITORY, AS
OUR ECONOMY GETS BACK IN FULL
SWING, AFTER THE PANDEMIC.
>> Tucker: IT IS JUST
TRANSITORY.
IT IS THE PRICE OF PROGRESS.
AT $7 BACON.
YEAH, BUT LOOK AT WHAT YOU ARE
GETTING IN RETURN.
ON THINGS GREAT?
UNTIL A FEW HOURS AGO, THAT WAS
THE OFFICIAL LINE IN WASHINGTON,
ALONG WITH THOSE DELAYS WERE
CAUSED BY WEATHER AND OUR
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN WAS
ACTUALLY A HUGE SUCCESS, WHAT
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
THAT IS WHAT THEY WERE TELLING
US.
AND THEN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ATLANTA FED, MN CULT CALLED
RAFAEL BOSTIC, ADMIT IT WAS VERY
OBVIOUS TO ANYONE WHO GOES TO TS
INFLATION, REAL INFLATION, NOT
TRANSITORY INFLATION AND IS
GOING TO BE HERE A LONG TIME.
WHAT HE DID NOT SAY IS THIS IS
NOT AN ACT OF GOD, NOT A
HURRICANE OR EARTHQUAKE OR
SOMETHING WE CAN'T CONTROL.
THIS IS THE RESULT OF DECADES OF
POLICY THAT HAVE ENRICHED A FEW